yo attack 975 Ready Set Radio bootleg
cap we got my man Wiz Khalifa what's
good man sup dude I'm chilling uh first
things first man congrats on the year
bro Joe been a long time coming man not
thank you man I appreciate that I've
been I think like the first like mixtape
I really messed with the star power like
of course you had on you know say yeah
yeah but but I really didn't catch on it
so star power no it's all good you know
um all that work even before that that
is up until now you don't say put me
worry about now so yes all good on a
cabin fever was tired you're out of the
fans who just got onto it yesterday
Michelle for show hey man um no we're
actually just talking you got the album
dropping your other papers Mars 29
highly anticipated man yeah people
weren't that dad that our marwar to is
crazy the covers yo yo design it um the
good people at Atlantic you know that's
dumb it was a collaboration between
great minds and of course green powers
now a lot of people um I guess a lot of
the criticism that you get I think a lot
of people feel like you know like they
wanted they want to try to category
categorize you as a weed rapper yeah um
of course the album's called rolling
papers so of course that is expected but
is there any other any other sort of you
know direction you go with with the
outlet all in um I'm gonna I'm gonna do
what I do want to help him you know
music please keep it Wiz anybody yeah
it's like anybody who knows me knows
what I do musically and they know how
how how much I work yeah I'm in said you
know my own growth right and changing it
up and not really worried about what
people have to say um I don't mind what
people you know think I am if they think
I'm a wee driver if they think I'm a
party rapidly think I'm a dance right
extreme
underground you know people want to say
what they gonna say end of the day I'm
going to just making music now you were
uh you were just on the cover of Rolling
Stone I am still in the cover yeah we
have to saw it online and we actually
just got it in the mail here oh dude
that's that's crazy cuz I just remember
like I go maybe like a year ago you know
you were you were kind of like you know
you had to cope following online head
and you know people who are into her
head to you but now you're on the cover
Rolling Stone twerking what has been the
moment where you've like been hit like
damn I'm like a superstar now oh there's
any one moment that that stall not yet
you know I'm just really consumed in the
work part yeah no I'm saying every day
I'm just trying to home build and learn
and just get new new new knowledge on
what I'm doing you know the San just be
better as a person as an artist as a
businessman um rolling stone had been on
me since day one oh yeah and they put me
in in there when I was in high school is
like artists to watch video it just
being featured on the coverage is big
you notice anything it's just good to
know the day even felt like following up
and a sharp a lot of people know why
people don't know or understand why but
they will you know and that's just the
beauty of this whole project his home is
a surprise even when its interface
people still get surprised definitely
what would um as far as rolling papers
is concerned yeah when it drops what are
your expectations Manny are you look I
mean do you care if you if you go number
one or you just want to get it off I
really just want to get it out I want
people to be excited about the music I
want people to receive it for what it is
and you know I want to just have that
platform to just move on to the next
project as well I'm not trying to make
anything or anybody gets stuck right
there yeah I just want to make something
great for me to build off of and
something for my fans to be happy about
and then we're gonna go to the next
thing that's what's up man one more time
rolling papers yeah March 20-29 yeah
don't worry about the next thing worry
about Mars 20 large 29 rolling papers
you got currency on now my so I hear
about the hill mad thank you many people
like who want to know it really only
matters if I got my people from Hebron
you guys gotta drop another mixtape
together it's gonna happen man currency
were always gonna be best friends dog
Mac Mac Miller McDowell well that Mills
not on the album here but wet watch out
for max he's
cover w tell that's what it is a Latino
what happens when those pics / oh boy
shoutout to everybody for piss right
let's get into your next time I want you
introduced before us look at that song
with too short yeah oh yeah well let's
do it man is me and the homie too short
or my love while rolling papers March
29th let's get it